crois que vous aurez encore l'occasion
de revenir sur ce sujet un autre thème
hier carlos ghosn a fui le japon il a
convoqué des dizaines de journalistes du
monde entier devant lesquels il s'est
livré à un show impressionnant défendant
bec et ongles son innocence expliquant
qu'il n'avait pas fui la justice mais
fluide pour obtenir la justice
il est entouré de dizaines d'avocats des
meilleures agences de communication il a
commencé ce matin une autre offensive
mondiale à travers les médias ses
avocats est-ce qu'il en ferait trop
on écoute ce matin la colère de la
ministre japonaise compétitivité de nos
têtes allez va goûter qui n'assure au
couteau manille
on a connu notre hôtel où étaient jetés
au sol ivoirien ne tarit du congo
cognitives
on a cogné au sénat qui est ici porté 18
93 elle concerne c'est un passionnant
dans un poteau sur nos animaux alors
j'espère que vous avez tout compris
sophie obadia qu'est ce que vous en
pensez cette idée de fuir la justice
pour mieux obtenir justice les chips à
hassoua pas ce qu'on appelle le forum
shopping chez les avocats vous
choisissez la loi la plus favorable non
mais sérieusement ce que dit la ministre
de la justice japonais tout est dit
c'est formidable de commencer son
allocution disons s'il doit se défendre
mais bien sûr qu'il doit se défendre
donc effectivement culturellement nous
avons quand même le sentiment que le
ministre japonais de la justice a une
vraie difficulté à considérer et a
demandé à monsieur ghosn d'apporter les
preuves pour sa défense je rappelle pas
avait alors que je rappelle ce n'est pas
à lui d'apporter les preuves de
l'accusation dont il fait l'objet
donc effectivement il ya un renversement
qui étaient cinq et on met ça je l'avais
signalé il ya très longtemps
in le japon on a le droit de le dire ne
présente pas les critères normaux des
droits de la défense qui sont un corpus
essentiel dans le monde occidental et je
pense que c'est un paradoxe exceptionnel
que ce soit monsieur carlos ghosn qui
devient le petit devienne le parangon de
2,7 comment dire de cette valeur
fondamentale qui doit être la nôtre
alors est ce que ça donne le droit de
fuir à dredge arguments juridiques
j'aurais de verre je réponds à votre
question
le droit de fuir il est contenu c'est
comme ça c'est un peu cynique ce que je
vous expliquais mais quand quelqu'un est
élargie c'est à dire quand ils sortent
de détention et qu'il est sous contrôle
judiciaire
ici dans notre pays la fuite elle est
toujours envisageable
voilà ça fait partie non pas des droits
de la défense mais des risques d'un
système judiciaire équilibré qui
effectivement donne des droits à celui
qui peut se défendre y compris le droit
d'être à l'extérieur et de consulter ses
avocats et d'être près de sa famille ce
que dit carlos est envisagée ne veut pas
dire qu'elle est légal qu'est ce qu'on
vit bien et les voies légales mais elle
fait partie des risques sociaux du
risque c'est un cas prévus par le copain
non c'est pas un cas prévu mais la
pratique ce fait que lorsque l'on remet
en liberté une personne on s'expose à un
risque de fuite
mais encore faut-il que lorsqu'on est en
liberté on puisse profiter des éléments
naturels de ça des votes favorables à sa
défense c'est à dire voir ses avocats
communiquer librement et voir sa famille
vous avez bien compris que carlos ghosn
quand on lui a présenté l'avenir comme
étant assez noire à savoir qu'il
n'aurait pas un procès rapidement je
parle même pas des kits et du procès
mais de droit à être jugé dans l'année
ça n'était même pas présenté comme tel
je ne dis pas que c'est bien de le faire
évidemment que je n'encourage pas la
fuite mais c'est un risque qui est pris
en compte je dirais par le système
judiciaire lorsqu'il est équilibré et
bien pensé comme un autre par exemple en
tout cas mieux que celui du japon c'est
certain nicolas corato puisse commencer
de cette situation pour le moins
atypique
moi je vais pas défendre le système
judiciaire japonais personnel et
personne ne peut le défendre je crois
que personne est en état de le défendre
ceci étant dit cela couronne est oui
c'est exceptionnel en même temps c'était
préférence de presse c'était pas des
conférences de presse des deux master
class et c'était quelque chose de
complètement hors norme enfin vous les
journalistes aient jamais connues une
conférence de presse comme ça on avait
l'impression qu'à la fois il présentait
les résultats de son groupe mais en fait
c'étaient ses résultats personnels
il nous a appris la vie moi j'ai compris
comment fonctionne et l'évasion fiscale
c'est un tuto formidable mondiale en
plusieurs langues en arabe en anglais un
peu en france est d'ailleurs un peu en
français en terme de communication
cesser complètement à cerneaux venir
moi j'avais jamais vu quelque chose
d'aussi bon je remarque d'ailleurs je
reprends on a des hommes des dirigeants
français qui quand même savent
mondialiser leurs problématiques
judiciaire dominique strauss kahn carlos
ghosn je crois que la france a une
filière intéressant qu'en la matière
plus sérieusement ça pose quand même une
question sur le conflit entre pardon de
le dire mais une forme de mondialisation
et la souveraineté des états c'est à
dire que on a là un ex dirigeant d'un
très grand groupe mondialisé qui a
réussi a finalement allés choisir son
tribunal non pas judiciaire mais
médiatique dans un pays dont il a la
nationalité et où il a pu se réfugier
avec des moyens qui sont les siens et
qui arrivent à se soustraire à une
justice quels que soient ses défauts
mais une justice souveraine et ça ça
pose une vraie difficulté ça pose une
rig de fidélité parce que comme vous le
disiez la fuite fait partie des
hypothèses mais si demain tout pays
considèrent que tous cadres dirigeants
mis en cause dans une affaire de
corruption de fraude fiscale ne doit
plus être en résidence surveillée mais
nécessairement incarcéré parce qu'il ya
la paix enfin je veux dire de la vie des
hommes d'affaires dans le monde va
commencer à être un peu plus difficile
qu'elle ne l'était déjà aujourd'hui et
et moi j'ai quand même une dernière
difficulté mais gerland les hommes
d'affaires ne suffisait pas non mais il
pouvait le faire mais ce qui s'est passé
là c'est vraiment je pense politiquement
ça pose
il y à un frottement très fort entre la
mondialisation de la souveraineté des
états le fait que effectivement lié une
population de cadres dirigeants de
grands dirigeants qui échappent d'une
certaine manière ce qu'un versement
souvent la justice n'est pas
instrumentalisée à des fins d'économies
mais parfois évidemment dans la sphère
gones on sait que c'est une affaire qui
est bien plus compliquée que d'ailleurs
il l'a il l'a parfaitement démontré en
tout cas de son point de vue hier
moi j'ai un dernier point qui est un peu
sentimental mais je pense et il
personnel que le liban n'avait pas
besoin de ça et que pour l'état libanais
la présence de carlos ghosn sur son
territoire est un problème diplomatique
majeur d'après des diplomates hic est un
problème intérieur et que
voilà je pense que ce matin c'est à dire
je connais mais ce petit pays qui est un
grand pays de coeur et de personnes
n'avaient pas besoin en ce moment alors
qu'il a il est face à un enjeu intérieur
majeur de venir faire la une est
d'accueillir quelqu'un qui est poursuivi
pour corruption et fraude fiscale alors
que vous avez des millions ou la paix
des milliers de libanais qui descendent
dans la rue puisque abus de confiance
et comment il faut lire du coup
l'interdiction de sortie du territoire
qui est que le liban a signifié
aujourd'hui basse et politique
ces politiques et c'est une réaction il
faut lire comme comme à l'achat ajouté
encore je pense qu'il faut le dire comme
le résultat d'un certain nombre de
pressions
et de réactions imposé à l'état libanais
etc ce qui pose encore là problème de la
souveraineté des états carlos ghosn à
chaque fois qu'il en soit on va le voir
dans son affaire va poser constamment le
problème de la souveraineté de l'état et
que ce soit la souveraineté de l'état
libanais la souveraineté de l'état
japonais et on va le voir est confronté
à des manifestations importantes
actuellement voilà exactement et on se
dira si l'état français contre dès qu'on
aborde le sujet tope là tout le monde se
tout le monde se planque
c'est assez laconique les minis sont
interrogés on entend la des matinales
évidemment le sujet est dans toutes les
bouches
c'est service minimum carlos ghosn est
un justiciable comme un autre
quand même à mélina un kinoïde
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes qui nous dit ce n'est pas
une
ce n'est pas une affaire française
l'idée c'est franchement un peu quand
même et quelques flèches contre l'as
mâcon hier il ya eu quelques flèches
contre et emmanuel macron alors ça les
relations entre carlos ghosn et emmanuel
macron sont notoirement mauvaises depuis
que le jeune ministre de l'économie en
2015 avait fait rentrer montée l'état au
capital sans prévenir sans prévenir
quatorze gones à l'époque et puis il a
tué l'avocat de carlos ghosn attaque
aussi bruno le maire qui se défend en
disant moi j'ai fait mon rôle est
actionnaire c'est tout ce qu'il dit
d'ailleurs il ya un embarras ya un vrai
embarras sûr sûr sûr ce cas là ce qui
rejoint complètement ce que vous dites
sur la souveraineté des états mathieu
soutien qu'est ce que vous pensez et
notamment cette comparaison la avec
l'arrestation de son arrestation et
pearl harbor est ce que vous pensez que
ça mais c'est quoi le oui j'étais pas au
courant mais est-ce que les américains
étaient au courant de pearl harbor a
effectivement pas parallèles discutable
non je mettais un bémol quand même sur
des skis et teligent je partage le fond
et en même temps enfin je ne sais pas
l'avenir est plus incertain que le passé
par définition mais on voit bien que
carlos ghosn ne parviendra pas
indéfiniment à se soustraire à la
justice
donc là il ya quelque chose de
spectaculaire on est dans une sorte de
film d'action
il s'est échappé avec un jet à tout ça
fait forcément fantasmer un peu tout le
monde
la malle gros machin le truc bon il a
réussi à se soustraire à la justice
japonaise temporairement
il ne pourra pas éternellement se
soustraire à la justice voilà donc à la
fin quand même on peut se dire que quel
que soit l'instance judiciaire qui
tranchera tout ça justice sera rendue
et il aura à rendre des comptes sur ce
qu'il dit et quand même reproché voilà
il ya quelque chose de très
spectaculaire il ya effectivement une
conférence de presse qui est totalement
hors norme avec une grande agence de
communication française si ça n'est pas
une affaire française
le réseau were tout ça et tout ça est
quand même s'échangent pignon public
comme ça ce qui est quand même important
voilà comment dans le cadre du procès
qui l'attend un manque ablement vous
avez raison l'opinion publique aura été
quand même préparé à écouter
favorablement sa défense bien plus que
s'il est rsa au singe a pondu ça je n'y
crois pas trois secondes ça qu'on peut
tous émettre des réserves sur le système
judiciaire japonais que comme beaucoup
de gens j'imagine j'ai un peu découvert
à l'occasion du procès gones jeu j'étais
surpris qu'une démocratie non occidental
puisse malgré tout avoir un système
judiciaire qui fonctionne de telle façon
je me souviens que chez nous j'étais
conseiller ministériel quand on a fait
évoluer certaines lois pour passer à 96
heures je crois le délai de garde à vue
dans des affaires de terrorisme et
toutes les associations et toutes les
associations manifestèrent
rétrospectivement on peut dire à juste
titre pour porter la question des
libertés publiques dans le débat et
c'est quand on va carlos ghosn après 120
jours je crois au japon je sais plus
combien enfin effectivement on n'est pas
exactement sur les mêmes critères
pour autant je ne suis pas convaincu en
fait que même si on a pu être
impressionnés par l'exercice d'hier
fondamentalement le prévenu gomme comme
disait la justice japonaise à la fin
bénéficiera dans l'île dans l'opinion
d'un soutien très favorable alors en
attendant que la question de pardon
justement là-dessus la question de sa
rémunération
elle faisait quasiment chaque année déjà
polémique chez nous alors allez vous en
parler elle était déjà considéré comme
hors norme et se pose ce brave carlos
ghosn n'a jamais su se contenter
manifestement de ce qui était sa
rémunération officielle et il à répondre
quand même de quatre affaires au total
où je sais pas alors en attendant de
justement de vision
au fisc il revendique déjà ses droits à
la retraite pour couper nos deux sujets
du soir on désire absolument pas
l'intention d'abandonner mes droits
j'ai des droits vis-à-vis de l'islam
j'ai des droits vis-à-vis de renault qui
n'ont pas été respectées et je compte
bien les réclamer en justice parce que
je crois dans la justice française et je
crois d'une certaine manière aussi du
bois sur le plan civil à la justice puis
japonaise alors sophie obadia qu'est ce
que vous en pensez de ses droits à la
retraite
alors évidemment ce n'est pas l'âge et
cargo non c'est sa nouvelle occasion
droit et d'essence ne sont pas si bonnes
et oui le travail décent mais en même
temps doit pas les confondre c'est la
difficulté c'est à dire qu'on ne doit
pas le juger au regard de sa fortune
quand il dit je ne suis pas au dessus je
ne suis pas en dessous c'est très
difficile de nos jours d'être juste
c'est à dire de regarder le cas carlos
ghosn dans ces affaires qui lui sont
imputées avec les charges qui sera
portée contre lui et la défense qui peut
apporter
l'orece je dirais qu'ils soient riches
qu'il soit qu'il soit avare qu'il soit
même particulièrement obsédé par
l'argent
peut-être mais ça n'est pas vraiment le
sujet est ce que réellement les faits
qui lui sont reprochés et il a l'air de
dire mais je n'en sais strictement rien
qui ne s'était pas encore voté les
sommes pour lequel et lesquels il est
poursuivi au japon c'est ça qui va
falloir examiner dans le faux le port
ils avaient pris leur proposeront
également d'avoir soustrait encore une
fois l'an fisc de des sommes
considérables
d'abord les deux infractions qui sont
reprochés c'est de s'être fait voter des
sommes qui aurait accru cesser ces
rémunérations sans en avoir averti
l'ensemble faisais ma part c'est là leur
première phase
voilà mais pour répondre à votre
question précisément est ce qu'il en
fait trop
bien sûr qu'il en fait trop quand
aujourd'hui il répond à la ministre
de la justice japonaise ridicule là
c'est trop évidemment qu'il va trop loin
et que c'est un personnage excessif ça
nous en sommes tous d'accord mais faudra
le juger pour ce qu'il a fait sa
personnalité viendra aussi éclairer les
faits mais pas que sa personne à
l'imagerie juste avant qu'on passe à un
autre sujet oui parce que ce qu'il dit
là quand tu dis j'ai pas du tout renoncé
mais droit renault nissan doivent ce
dont il parle c'est sa retraite gelé
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
certes en plus de 700000 euros par an
hélas ce qui est ce qu il adresse un
message direct ni sales et nouveau tracé
une retraite qu'on négocie pour le jour
où on partira pour le jour où on prend
sa retraite parce qu'avec son alliance
est une rente à vie et rien à racler
klein lance un débat et un message
direct il dit mais je n'ai pas du tout
démissionner ils ont voulu faire croire
que j'avais démissionné
c'est un débat rap et technique je me
suis mise en retrait pour assurer un
crise aux numéros sociaux moraux de
lancer je n'ai jamais démissionné à
faire tous les pros c'est possible voilà
exactement ils sont dans une espèce de
guerre qui va être à la fois technique
et enfin tout ce qu'on veut mais
voilà ce qu'il veut récupérer fait c'est
beau c'est en tout cas hier se parent
aviv
c'est vrai comme vous disiez ce show a
quand même convaincu une grande partie
de nos internautes qui ont répondu à 58%
qu'ils étaient convaincus par sa
déclaration ils étaient 84 mille votants
et les commentaires sont assez partagés
sur le site carlos ghosn mange à tous
les râteliers ou bien babineau nous dit
carlos ghosn est un showman mais son
image est définitivement entaché passant
un autre sujet autre polémique et ne
l'ont même pas dit à la reine celle et
diane et harry qui eux aussi veulent se
faire la malle
ils ont annoncé qu'ils voulaient prendre
leur distance ac la famille royale ils
sont désireux de travailler d'acquérir
une liberté financière et ils
s'installent ont une partie de l'année
en amérique